hi i'm alvin hi it's inca and we are in
the tasty kitchen and we're gonna watch
our favorite episode of making a pig
also the only episode i'm in so
naturally right
let's watch the episode
can we screen cap this how do you
it's already screen it's already
recording it's recording i just wanted
to oh my god there you go it's going to
be a meme all right welcome back
we don't need to watch the intro right
why are you watching i'm tasting
personally i've been a fan of sumo
wrestling for a very long time you
should do the intro he was are you a fan
of sumo wrestling yeah it's so fun i've
watched documentaries on them i've
watched i straight up watch
documentaries i've never seen elm and i
hang out a lot and i have never seen him
mention a single word of simmer i
watched it at night okay he was in ed
sheeran's music video wait shape of you
he's he's been around the block this
guy's actually famous this was really
surprising to me well actually no
because i know they normally eat uh what
is that called
which is very healthy right one of my
dreams is to cook for a sumo wrestler
like you what giant food would you like
me to make why is that stop my goal is
to cook for a summer wrestler like you
what kinds of ingredients do you like in
your ramen cashew egg okay
green onion okay
seaweed
that's it okay what kind of broth do you
like uh
oh me too exactly i think i can do it
man oh thank you appreciate it okay also
if you guys that was a reference i threw
in
not a lot of people got it but
his agent told me that he was a pretty
big anime fan it's called attack on
titan this is their salute he caught it
after the camera stopped rolling and he
secretly got excited about it and that
was pretty awesome but nobody else
caught it so uh
i've got a lot to do i'm gonna have to
call in some backup
dude how many times did it take us to do
this correctly this took 15 minutes like
on the run of show i allotted five
minutes for apron shots we literally
took 20 minutes guys this is my friend
inka she's a producer at buzzfeed she's
made some amazing videos you might have
seen a lot of the cool stuff that she's
done this is when i did the ostriches oh
yes
giant food i did it first she
technically did it first it was a really
good brush like there was a lot of
really good ingredients that went in
there oh my goodness that's what i like
to see
might take a while that's what i'd like
to see why am i like this dude no why
are you like this i don't know ready
what is those these are what is
no i want to find a more unflexible you
can go frame by
frame no this is two
can we zoom in on this oh yeah somebody
make a meme out of this please okay
wait you know silence
the guy in the group projects that just
like sits back does nothing and then
just like shows up on the last day i was
like oh hey guys how's it going oh you
finished oh thanks thanks for the eight
alvin talks a lot he does talk
usually it's just lonely yeah this this
was the first show lonely and you it's
true this was the first time i've had
like someone else cooking with me
because usually it's just me and there's
a camera right there and it's i mean i'm
not as good at it so it's hard for me to
continually like pretend or narrate but
it's like so much easier to like have
someone there to like actually talk to
so i was like oh this is way more fun
because i don't have to like
talk to an empty void of a camera so
thanks dude
you just did the exact same thing you
did it
it just went on for i don't know how
long you can tell that there's a lot of
what is it gluten gluten yes
there is a lot of blue did you see my
boy gluten are you damn right i did
it's my boy gluten yeah you were because
you were using your tippy toes in the
way i couldn't like i don't know maybe
my arms are just not jacked enough
i have to use my own way even like the
biggest bakers they're like you
literally they're rocking did you just
smack you just like smacking things
yes
[Applause]
zero is the thickest setting we're gonna
start with that and hold this is your
concentration face that
yeah yours is
what i don't know you go like yeah like
that there we go
okay not bad so that's the beginning one
of the reasons why
this video needs to be a two-person
video is because of this we have the
fettuccine attachment she just cooked it
as
hey i do that face it's amazing i've
never seen you do that face
all right
hold it tight this is hard
this was hard because it was so slippery
yeah there was there was so much fat
okay this liquid in itself
was amazing
it's like
it tasted really sweet and savory this
is an ostrich egg and this is a normal
egg a normal egg for reference
you versus the guy she tells you not to
worry about this is not easy
people like that quote
i don't even remember i remember you
saying no i remember you saying it i was
like i gave you a look and then they did
it they called i'm sure you gave me
minnie this feels like a okay can we
just talk about how
like
i had an ostrich egg a while back
and i asked alvin if i should make a
giant ramen and he said no don't do it
do it an
egg sandwich next thing i know he's like
i'm doing a giant ramen i'm like alvin
but then he brought me to do this with
him so that's all good
i was coerced
sumo wrestler said he wanted a nice soft
boiled egg
literally no way this is going to go in
the water do you want to give it a name
eggy okay
cute egg baby hang out and what does
eggy sound like in korean
eggy is baby in korean
feels like a water balloon i was just
going to say that you know that feeling
when you're like
about to do something and then something
just feels very wrong
yes this is what it was like it is
definitely not this is not right this is
not what a soft boiled egg should be
like
hold on let's go back oh my gosh how do
you screen cap this oh did you just
screenshot oh here we go this is not
your computer nobody needs this no no no
you did one i get to do one too excuse
me
here we go um so can someone make this a
meme
as well okay ignore this honestly this
is so jiggly
oh
emotional support wouldn't be bad though
good job alvin you got this outfit you
can do it alvin you want to name it
eggy junior
can i draw a face on it just for good
luck
we miss becky yeah this is a good
drawing cute yay
oh i did that at the same time he's so
cute he is so cute alvin has one shot
alvin's one shot
okay
[Music]
sometimes children don't turn out the
way you want them to and that's right
alvin
all of this stuff went into that broth
we actually took this hope the leftovers
yes
that came out so perfect amazing yes it
was i was like
this is probably one of the best things
we've made on the show six slices and
hopefully that is interesting those are
huge yeah those were huge they're like
half of my face more importantly oh this
one yeah the best thing ever about this
shoot this bowl we got this bowl
either home depot or like those
department stores that sell planters
because we didn't find a bowl big enough
so we had to really go to the like we
had to go to non-bowl section to find
one we could sear it in a pan or here we
go
or
oh my god
[Music]
time to get lit
okay oh yeah oh my god
we had to do this
like 30 times so many times 30 times
like definitely i don't know if it's
exactly 30 but over 20 times it's
literally just like time to get lit and
i just wanted to cry all right agent lam
proceed to target legit lamb fire it
will
[Music]
at this point i really wanted it i was
just gonna say that yeah this is our
ramen this is this is a romance i was
genuinely nervous
yeah if he was going to like it i really
wanted him
did good
a little laugh i was so nervous and i
was so excited because he was so excited
look at him open your eyes
he loves it
pretty cool right you like it yeah
i know i loved his reaction so much how
do you feel
very exciting
are you hungry yeah very hungry
no it's like that feeling of like
you know when you cook for somebody
right and then you see them really like
it and like his face is literally this
look of pure joy genuine yeah
like i know he's been on tv he's done a
lot of movies but i felt like that was
sincerely genuine that was really
awesome i honestly did not know what to
expect right oh it was so satisfying
look at me i'm so happy
i'm like falling over because he's like
actually eating yamasan if you want to
come back we can make you some more food
it's a good man
what are you doing i'm trying to imitate
him my friends are coming here
he didn't say a word
yeah
wait but can we talk about how they
oh my
can we talk about how they actually
finish the entire bowl like right there
on the set yeah he ate for like 15
seconds he didn't say a word
came up for air and was like umai which
means yum and that was like
[Music]
[Music]
that was cool yeah i haven't watched
that in a while i know it's been a while
i feel like a lot of the moments though
we're still reacting and the same i know
we're the same person but like like the
initial action but like even looking at
it again seeing it visually hearing the
sounds looking at the sizzle it was
still like i could i still remember how
it feels
and like the actual going through it
like
we
it was it was so fun like it was just so
fun doing that you wanna do some more
yeah yeah
we're gonna make it happen thank you for
having me alvin thanks for watching and
let us know what you guys liked about
this episode about other episodes
there's any foods you want to see us
make send us our way but we're gonna see
you guys next time alright bye
yes
[Music]